[Music]
loyalty is in short supply on the big
screen
from science fiction epics to quentin
tarantino
actioners to comic book adaptations to
even family friendly animated flicks
here are the most shocking betrayals in
movie history in the wachowski siblings
genre defining 1999 sci-fi epic the
matrix
viewers were introduced to a world in
which humans have been dominated by
machines
after a lengthy war the sun's light has
been blocked out and people have been
placed into pods to live in the computer
simulated reality of the matrix
when tom anderson renamed neo learns the
truth from his mentor morpheus and his
right hand woman trinity
he chooses to leave the matrix behind
and return to the real world
he then finds himself in a run-down
dystopia where humans must hide from the
machines to survive
but trouble is brewing in morpheus crew
cipher played by joe pantaliano is
secretly working with the matrix's
band of evil agents treating his friends
livelihoods
for a comfortable life of ignorant bliss
ignorance is bliss in a shocking turn
during a mission he leaves the matrix
for the real world
and then brutally kills most of the
ship's crew it was a stunning betrayal
that left audiences reeling in the
aftermath
neo ultimately ends up saving the day
but cipher's actions
nevertheless have serious consequences
quentin tarantino's 1992
feature-length debut reservoir dogs put
the acclaimed director on the map in a
big way
throughout the movie the gang of thieves
attempting to pull off a diamond heist
are known
only by their code names mr white mr
blonde
mr pink mr blue mr brown and mr orange
after the heist goes terribly wrong the
group kidnaps a policeman
and tortures him in one of the film's
most brutal and unforgettable scenes
but before long the gang realizes that
there's a mole in their mist
mr orange who was injured during an
earlier shootout
confesses that he's an undercover cop
after he shoots and kills mr blonde
mr white is floored and devastated by
his friend's betrayal
he ultimately kills mr orange after a
standoff
and mr pink makes off with the diamonds
botching the entire heist and leaving
pretty much everybody else for dead
tarantino is no stranger to both shock
value and violence
and he would go on to feature even more
stunning betrayals in his career
but the one in reservoir dogs still
stands out as perhaps the most startling
twist in his filmography
in jordan peel's 2017 acclaimed horror
film
get out audiences are introduced to a
young couple
chris and rose who are headed to visit
rose's family for a weekend
though chris is initially nervous that
rose's family will disapprove of their
interracial relationship
rose assures him that there won't be any
problem so they head out to the remote
family estate in the country
after chris is introduced to rose's
parents missy and dean
and her erratic brother jeremy he starts
to settle in
but he also notices some strange things
throughout the house
especially the questionable behavior of
the black employees
after a party that goes awry chris wants
to leave
and rose readily agrees but there's just
one problem
chris can't drive as rose tauntingly
dangles the car keys in his face
he realizes that she's been in on her
parents gambit
all along she's actually been kidnapping
chris
as she has done with so many other black
lovers before
to steal his body for a wealthy white
patron to live in
allison williams performance as rose is
pitch perfect
making for one of the most heartbreaking
betrayals of all time
you were one of my favorites
christopher nolan's critically beloved
dark knight trilogy
features a darker side of bruce wayne's
story than what we've previously seen on
the big screen
and that storytelling lens extends to
some of batman's most famous villains
in the series middle installment 2008's
the dark knight
viewers are introduced in nolan's
pitch-black take on the joker
played to perfection by heath ledger
before his untimely passing but while
that performance has been deservedly
hailed as a classic
there's also another villain lurking in
plain sight
introduced as gotham's district attorney
the virtuous harvey dent
sets out to save gotham from low lifes
like the joker
but after the super villain kills dent's
girlfriend and bruce wayne's childhood
love rachel dawes
dent becomes a changed man inside and
out
with half his face blown off in an
explosion caused by the joker
dent becomes two-face known for flipping
a coin to decide who lives and who dies
in gotham
bruce wayne has very few allies to begin
with
and losing dent in his prime is a
serious blow
especially after they lose rachel the
love of both of their lives
wes craven's 1996 horror classic scream
is widely regarded as one of the
greatest slasher flicks of all time
thanks in large part to its clever
storytelling and gutting twist ending
the film focuses on sydney prescott a
high school student grappling with the
one year anniversary of her mother's
bloody death
amidst a new string of killings in the
sleepy small town of woodsboro
california
throughout the movie the knife-wielding
masked killer constantly stalks sydney
and her friends
the chase comes to a gruesome conclusion
during a party where the killer
dispatches most of sydney's classmates
as it turns out there's actually not one
but two killers
sydney's boyfriend billy and his goofy
pal stew have been working together
which explains how the masked ghost face
often seemed to be in two places at once
not only are they responsible for the
deaths of several teenagers
they were also the ones who killed
sydney's mom
why did you kill my mother why
why
that's due i think she wants a motive
ultimately
sydney and a few other survivors rally
together and kill
billy and stew themselves thus putting
an end to their spree
but this betrayal was undeniably a
horrible blow to sydney
and it's one that horror audiences won't
forget anytime soon
over the course of the harry potter
series the students of hogwarts end up
with a new defense against the dark arts
professor
every single year thanks to a
long-standing curse
in their fourth year as chronicled in
harry potter and the goblet of fire
that teacher is alistar maddy moody a
heavily scarred and formidable wizard
who bears a fake
eye with a mind of its own mad eye
teaches harry and his classmates some
pretty dangerous spells
while telling them to remain constantly
vigilant in the face of dangers like
lord voldemort and his death eaters
but as it turns out mad eye isn't who he
initially seems to be
or even mad eye at all as the
international tri-wizard tournament
comes to a close at hogwarts
harry discovers mad eye's horrifying
secret
he's actually a disguised barty crouch
jr
who's a wanted death eater using
polyjuice potion to impersonate mad eye
after getting close to someone he
thought he could trust throughout the
year
only to discover that his professor was
really a death eater trying to deliver
him to voldemort
harry feels betrayed and it's not hard
to understand why
martin scorsese's 2006 best picture
winning mob epic
that departed features plenty of
betrayals and backstabbing
but one character stands out among the
rest as the king of the doublecross
massachusetts state police officer colin
sullivan might seem like a fine
upstanding man
he's played by matt damon after all but
for years
he's been indebted to and working with
mob boss frank costello and his clan
serving as a mole within the fbi to keep
costello's empire running
but his days may be numbered when billy
costigan joins the police force
in secret to work as a mole within
costello's organization
and the two men scramble to uncover the
other mole
first unfortunately for costigan
sullivan is selfish to a fault and he
will stab
absolutely anybody in the back to save
his own skin
after enduring his own personal betrayal
when he finds out that frank has been
working as an informant for the police
for years
sullivan shoots frank his father figure
he then mows through
anyone else he can indirectly getting
costigan killed and directly killing
several
other police officers to try to salvage
his reputation
but in the end karma comes calling as
he's killed himself
at the 11th hour the original star wars
trilogy features plenty of beloved
characters
but few of them made as strong an
impression as the dashing
quick-witted con man lando calrissian
but not everything he did was
particularly lovable one of his most
shocking moments occurs in the second
film the empire strikes back
which sees him betray a close friend and
ally
when audiences first meet han solo's old
friend lando
the former gambler is working as the
administrator of cloud city
although lando welcomes han with open
arms that embrace isn't totally warm
as he ends up stabbing his friend in the
back when faced with threats from darth
vader
lando hands han over allowing him to be
encased in carbonite
while also giving leia and chewbacca
over to vader as well
thankfully lando is ultimately given the
chance to fully redeem himself
by helping leia and chewbacca escape in
the millennium falcon
and eventually rescue han from job of
the hutt
but in the moment his betrayal stings so
badly that fans are still talking about
it to this day
based on ian mcewen's award-winning
novel joe wright's 2007 period piece
atonement
spans several different time frames to
tell the story of star-crossed lovers
in 1930s england and their ultimate
fates both real and fictional
in 1935 a young bryony talis takes
notice as her beautiful older sister
cecilia begins a flirtation with robbie
their wealthy family's groundskeeper
briony also has feelings for robbie
and when she finds explicit letters from
him that are meant for cecilia
she gets the wrong idea and then when
she finds robbie and cecilia in a
compromising position in the family's
library
she tells her family that robbie
assaulted cecilia
afterwards robbie is accused of another
assault as well
and sent away to prison after serving
his prison sentence and also fighting in
world war
ii robbie starts a life with cecilia in
london
bryony goes to apologize to them thus
seemingly resulting in a happy ending
for all the main characters
but as it turns out this ending is a
fiction concocted by a much older briony
to atone for her sins
after bryony's false accusation of
robbie he died in the war before
ever having a chance to reunite with
cecilia while cecilia died in one of the
blitz bombings in london
by writing a happy ending for her sister
and robbie bryony attempts to repair her
betrayal
but unfortunately real life can't be
rewritten
and her betrayal lingers as one of the
most devastating betrayals anyone could
possibly imagine
even beyond its mega hit song let it go
disney's 2013 animated flick frozen is a
notable installment in the studio's
canon thanks to its clever plot and
subversion of typical disney
storytelling tropes
as the film begins viewers meet sisters
anna and elsa who must soldier on
after their parents tragic death despite
the rift between them caused by
elsa's magical ice-based powers during
elsa's coronation
as queen of arendelle anna falls head
over heels in love with the handsome
dashing prince hans who seems like the
perfect prince charming
despite elsa's misgivings about her
sister marrying somebody she's just met
anna and hans get engaged as it turns
out elsa was right to be suspicious
hans is far from a classic disney prince
as he's actually in arendelle to kill
both
anna and elsa and claim the throne for
himself and the southern isles from
which he hails
in the end just as hans is about to kill
elsa
anna sacrifices herself to save her
sister and elsa then saves her life in
return
even though anna does find her true love
in the end in the form of kristoff
it's the love between sisters not
romantic love that triumphs over
everything else as it proves powerful
enough
to overcome even the deadliest of
betrayals
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you